Hey, we're towards the end of the year, end of the week rather.
Easy Thursday, yeah.
Yeah, that's right. So looking forward to the weekend.
Yep, always them.
Yeah.
Especially with summer coming along.
That's cool.
True, that's true.
How about yourself?
Yeah, I am, as you mentioned, always looking for, I start looking out for the weekend on Mondays itself.
Very good, yep.
Natalie will be joining in a minute. Is Tim expected to join today?
I believe so. I'm not sure whether he confirmed the meeting or not.
Yeah.
Yeah, he actually did. He requested it to be at three, so...
To be, yeah, to be changed, I believe, so, yeah.
Yeah, he's a busy man. It can change.
Let me double check, because last when I checked it, who is...
Saying accepted for him. Let me quickly check.
Yep, says accepted.
Hi, Vishal.
We can give a...
Yeah.
Hi, Glenn. Very good evening. Nice to see you.
Hello, you as well.
Yep, so we can give two, three more minutes and then we can just wait.
Most definitely.
Yep.
At least here, and Natalie.
Hey, I made it.
Yep.
How are you guys?
I'm glad.
Hello.
In.
What's going on, Glenn?
Busy world, but hey, it's warming up a little bit and summer's almost here, so I can't complain.
Okay.
Oh yeah, for sure, for sure. I actually just realized my son put the air conditioner back on because I was getting chilly in here and I turned it off for a second, then he came back and put it on.
Yeah, Mother Nature can't make its mind up because for the last couple of weeks, we've had the heat on, the air conditioner on, back and forth. It's been crazy.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Is Tim, Tim's joining too, right?
As far as I'm aware, yes.
Yeah, I think we were moving it for.
And so, hopefully, you can make it.
Doesn't join here in the next moment, I'll take a walk down the hall and...
See if I can get him to join.
Yeah, that'll that'll work. What have you been doing summers coming up? What do you got going on?
Just normal travel plans. We like to camp, so get out, get outside in nature and enjoy that. Get away from the office a little bit, get away from the computers and just take it all in. We like to travel, so...
Yeah, that's awesome. That's what we used to do. I grew up in like Pennsylvania, like Pittsburgh, but we used to go to somewhere, the surrounding area, and that was our thing too. We would like go camping, go to the lake, get some paddle boats. That was a good, it was fun.
Yep.
We were just in the, we were just in Latrobe last weekend, and we're actually going out to Ohio Pile next, not this weekend, next weekend, so...
Okay, yeah.
Das.
I love Ohio Pile. I miss it. They have the, you go to where they have the man-made water slide.
Yep.
Yeah, yep.
Yeah, my son, my son's giggling. He's 19 now, but I used to take him there when he was a baby.
Yep.
It's what my daughter likes to do. Yep.
Yeah, yeah, I've always loved it. It's really cool. I've never done the white water rafting though. I have to someday.
Not our cup of tea, but maybe one day we'll do it.
Yeah.
Well, with my luck, I'm going to be the one that falls out anyway, so I'll just have to make sure I bring somebody strong to scoop me back up. What's up, Tim?
That's right.
Hello!
He made it. We were going to send Glenn after you. He was getting this, what are those called, brass knuckles? Yeah, I was getting those ready. I didn't know it was so aggressive, but...
You too.
Now, I'm glad, glad it didn't come.
Yeah, yeah, something's always a gun.
All right, well, Tim, since you're here, Manish, do you want to bring up the deck?
Yep, I can. One moment.
One moment, I just I had it on my screen and just lost it.
Am I throwing you a curveball? Do you think I was going to shoot?
Ohh, here it is.
I can share it too.
Just going up.
Tim, I appreciate you joining today. I know you're busy.
How's golfing?
No problem at all.
Golfing is not fun. I don't enjoy golfing. I like the golf cannon. I like the golf. I like the golf golf cannon. I'm in motor sports or so than golf. I enjoy just hanging out, having a good time, but it's not my it's not not my forte, but I like hanging out.
You tell the joy.
The.
Yeah, I think that's all I would be as well, because I've never been, I'm pretty good at most sports, but golf's never. It's always been like an awkward, like I can't even figure out if I'm the left or righty, if I'm being honest.
I can start.
Okay.
All right, so welcome to the QBR. Thank you both for joining today. We'll just be going through the first quarter here, looking at some metrics, and then I'll tell you some things that are going on with IT by design. So go to the agenda, Manish. So we got about 10 items on the agenda today. So we'll run through, just give you an overview of the leadership team here. We'll go through Carl's outcomes, look at some value drivers.
look at the performance metrics, go through Carl's CDG, and then I'll introduce you to some of the automations that we're doing here at IT by Design and some agent builds out that we have. And then we'll look at the way forward.
So just to kick it off, just to give you an idea of the team that you have here. So on the service delivery side, Manish is going to be your go-to as far as anything with Carl. Above him, we have Vishal who reports into Sameer. Javid is going to be overseeing service delivery at the end of the day. And then
Sunny's going to be your executive sponsor as far as at the executive level. And then on revenue and customer experience, Andy's going to be your customer success manager. I'm the associate director of CX. I report to Ankur, who's over revenue, and then we all report to Kam at the end of the day there. So any open door for anything you need.
just reach out to us.
K.
So we can go to the next slide.
So just going through some key outcomes that we identified with Carl. So he has a great, strong service performance. So his CSATs are always really good. Thank you for completing the MPS surveys. Really appreciate that. And then it seems like the ticket resolve is always high.
too. Utilization and volume is always strong with him. We have a lot of project contribution. So I know Manish broke down some different projects that he's been working on and really focuses in on the proactiveness with you guys. And then just as far as development, he's really open to expanding. Right now we're looking at the AZ104 certification.
and then he seems to jump in, exceed expectations, and then we find that he doesn't have too much idle time either whenever he's working. Any other outcomes that you can think of, Glenn, top of mind?
Not on the top of my head. He's a very helpful individual in regards to always goes the extra mile to make sure that things are completed and definitely does things as, you know, to our standard, if you will. So it's always very good to have him on the team.
Good, I'm glad to hear that.
All right, let's look at the next slide, Manish.
So we've kind of looked at what Carl's been doing for you and just broke it down into some business outcomes that we've seen. So just in general, you're working with IT by design. So the labor cost is going to be a little bit more. You're getting a senior level resource at a lower cost. So we're protecting gross margin there.
Operational continuity without internal risk. So just with him helping and keeping your environment secure. Security and compliance de-risk. So especially the Quark cyber deployment. I know that was huge for you guys and just making sure that any security gaps are able to get closed up and then you're remaining compliant.
and he's a strong character there. And then just, he is a scalable and appreciating asset in general. So Carl's growing with you. As he evolves with you, he's able to expand into deeper work. And then right now too, he's really gonna be focusing on the AZ104 and helping with the Azure.
All right, let's go into the next piece. So this is where we want to hear from you overall, what mattered most for you this quarter, and then what worked well from your perspective.
So what I would say as far as what's working, what's mattered most for us this quarter has really been our ability to move forward. We've done further expansion on some of the different various tools that we're rolling out, you know, one of which was mentioned was Quark. We're using that for gap analysis and then also just making sure that all of our tooling is, you know,
distributed to all of our endpoints accordingly and making sure they're all addressed in a timely manner. And then obviously on the what's worked well on our perspective is having him, having Carl on the alternate shift has really helped us maintain the
Yeah.
you know, patching and then also some of our after-hours support situations where, you know, it's not our waking hours, if you will. So being able to connect those dots and take care of some of those after-hours maintenance requirements has really been beneficial for us in the last, you know, quarter.
and half a year if you will.
No, that's awesome. And then I know Manish, you mentioned too, like he's an important piece, making sure that the VIP clients, the 24 by 7 clients are staying happy and taken care of too. So it's good to hear that.
All right, well then let's look at the metrics. Manish, I'll pass it over to you.
Thank you, Natalie. So talking about the performance for Q1, like from January to April, numbers have never been an issue with Carl. He's always exceeded the numbers. Okay, so, and in fact, it is a consistent performance that we're looking at right now. So
Eighty-eight percent is the consistent one, and, like, at the time when this stick was prepared, it was at eighty-six for the 8th month of April. OK, so...
Though it was still the month was still going on, so it was a slight dip, 86%, but we above the target that we have set up. So no issues or no challenges on the numbers, as I mentioned. CSAT 100% from your side, as his roles are.
Like he majorly works off hours, so client interactions are really less. So the only CSATs that we're getting is from your side and we have always got the positive CSAT. So really good to know on that one. And for if you talk about the NPS, like we've always got a positive or in fact put.
the NPS scores from your side, you must, Tim, normally the NPS scores or the links are sent to you. You must have received the latest one. So if you can take some time to fill that out, that would be a great help.
Yep, I'll go through and look for it, but it's going to be high scores. There's no issue. He's going to get the top score, whatever that is.
Yeah.
Thank you. Glad to hear that. Yeah.
Well, well, Manish, we should scale it back. The MPS is more for like everybody. So even though if Carl is exceptional, that's great, but it is really for us to know if.
We can.
Yes.
Yeah.
Ohh, it's a whole team, so I get to, I get to rate, I get to rate the whole the whole IT by design team, then that's what it's for.
Yes, yeah, you can top down, girl, whoever you want.
Yes, that's true.
Yes.
Ohh, I'm changing my, I'm changing my now, I gotta take everything back and start.
Ben.
Yeah.
It.
Listen, you're entitled to your own feedback.
No, it's still gonna be rated rated very highly, so...
Awesome, thank you, Tim.
Yeah, I know it's all good.
Okay, yep. Moving on to the next one. Ticket resolution, that is another KPI that we gauge our engineers on. So again, a consistent performance that we're looking at right now. So I've also done a breakdown of different kind of tickets that he's working on.
This is ideally the same data that we go ahead and present to Glenn on our monthly connects. So if you talk about like month on month, above 200 tickets that were closed out, like as I mentioned,
given a breakdown of it. So 63% were the infrastructure and maintenance tickets that he worked on. Then 22% was the security, which included webroots, cork, and spam filter tickets. Then we had 8% of the disaster recovery testing that he has performed.
Along with that, there were a few after our calls that he has also addressed that included the VIP callers, as so Ashley just mentioned. So, 7% of those, so 886 tickets were the total tickets that were addressed during this particular quarter.
And in case any questions or anything you want to talk about, Glenn, because these are the numbers which we normally showcase to you. Any questions you have in here before I move on to next?
I don't have any questions myself now, I'm good.
Awesome, that's really good, yeah.
I, yeah, I have a quick, I have a quick question before we before we move on, and this is a general question at all, and I just don't know if this has been looked at yet, but for like an area of growth, you know, we could get these 800 tickets, we could, you know, process them through AI and see if there are ones that
Yeah.
we can start to automate so Carl can do higher level things than lower level things. I don't know if that's been looked into yet, but that's something I would have interest in, kind of go on a go forward basis, see how we can leverage Carl in a higher level capacity than just cleaning desk space or something like that potentially. Just want to, we can talk about it later, but that's.
One thing, one thing of interest, I'd like to see if that's something that we can, at a PCH we can do some of that, but if that's something that we could potentially leverage.
Sure, Tim. Natalie, you want to take that one regarding our AI program?
Well, yeah, I mean, well, I think there's two pieces to it, right? There's the AI piece, which we have our whole AI by design division, and then there's us looking at Carl's expertise and where he can support with AI too. So I think there's going to be two pieces to it as well.
Play.
Yeah.
Tim, we do have our AI by design entire section, or I would say that will come up in a later slide. So we do have our AI automation tasks available, and for which we will be, we can talk about it in a bit.
Okay, so moving on to next one. This is the Easy 104, the career development plan that we have created for Carl. So he is actually inclined towards completing the Easy certification while to
step into the Azure world. So I mentioned the different stages in there. So he will be working on his certification and as soon as it is done, I will be sharing that news with you, Claire.
Very good.
Okay, so moving on to the next piece. Yeah, Natalie, over to you for the EIPs. Yep.
We made it. Yeah, here we go. So, yeah, where are you at right now, Glenn, as far as like the automation journey? Where is PCH?
So we have a lot of automations in the background, and we're also utilizing Kaseya, so CooperBot, and quite a few other platforms. We utilize hats quite a bit as well, internally as one of our biggest things and initiatives. So we are utilizing that, and we do have other strategic initiatives that we're also working on.
Megan.
in the background on the management side of things to move things forward on the, you know, AI front.
Gotcha. And then have you started, since you're using hats, or you're reselling that to your customers as well? That's part of.
That's correct, yes.
Okay, gotcha. Well...
Yep, yeah, so we're, yeah, we're, yeah, we're kind of far along on the AI as a service journey. I think that there's areas in the automation that we could potentially get a little bit better on. That's why there's some things here, it's like a no-brainer that we could, in Carl's role, leverage areas where.
We can make it more efficient and have him doing high-value things in the future, for sure.
Yeah, is Carl doing any, there is RMM automation. Is he currently working on that too, or he hasn't been working too much in the RMM automation?
Not on the RMM automation at this time, no.
Okay, but because I think Manish, she does have that skill set though, right?
Yes, he is good with the scripting part, so he can work on that. And I believe just to touch that AIP, so he's done the HAT certification at PCH level, so he has already.
gone through that particular certification. I believe that was done in.
maybe mid of last year. That's when it was done.
Yeah.
I believe that was Q3.
Okay, yeah, I don't know, Manish, if you just want to schedule a separate call with Glenn and Carl, just kind of going through exactly, and maybe Tim, you should probably be there too. But let's see some stuff. I know that when he was on an account before, he did a lot of different stuff with the RMM, so maybe we can start bringing that over here.
As well, and then we'll look at his capacity too, so we won't overload him and then just let have him let us know, like, if if the work's becoming too much, if we're adding that into his scope.
And then on the back side, so AI by Design, just as a whole, we are doing AI assessments for free for our partners. So even if you want to see what your maturity level is at, we'll jump on a call with you, run through an AI assessment. We have accelerator trainings. Are you coming to build it this year?
Glen, Tim.
I will not be. I don't know about Tim.
Okay, Tim, are you going to be coming to build it?
Thumb you.
Sorry about that. Yeah, sorry about that. I think, is it the very, is the beginning of August?
Yeah, it's August 3rd through the 5th in Jersey City.
I'm going to be, I'm able to get you part of it. I'm going to be out at GTIAs at the same time in San Diego. I have to see when it, if there's any overlapping, overlapping days when that one is compared to yours, but I'm going to be at GTIA.
San Diego.
Okay, here, Manish, go to the next slide. So yeah, check what days that those are, because the last day is going to be our AI accelerator piece of it. So if you look at the AI accelerator, it will be the last day. So that's basically just going to go through everything with AI, how to market it, how to sell it.
K.
Right.
the AI maturity assessments, and then just anything that's new in the market as well.
Yeah, I'm looking at my count. I have GTA. Yeah, I have GTA on my calendar, the 3rd, the 4th and the 5th right now, but I don't know. I just blocked it. I don't know that the actual agenda, so I have to check the agenda and see what I can do from a scheduling perspective. So.
So, as far as...
Okay. Yeah, that sounds, that's what kind of sucks. We are overlapping with a couple events this year and then I think one of them got moved too at the same time. But we'll send you over the information. I have a code for you as well. So when you sign up, you'll have the BOGO code or I'll give you, I'll send you the.
Yeah.
Okay.
the pass so that you can get the ticket.
Thank you. Appreciate that.
But the agenda's out now too, so I'll send the agenda to you.
Yeah, send that out. I'll check that out. Yeah, thank you.
All right. I think we could pull it back, Manish.
Okay, so, yeah, good, good, good.
So, yeah, go ahead. You can do the way forward. I want you to do that.
Yeah, I was just talking about the way forward, like the agenda is to go through the easy 104 certification. So that's something me and Karl will be working on. Then, like we do have the KPI alignment that is like, so far we have confirmed it is 8 to 10 tickets A day.
We'll be talking about the automation piece as well, and we will be sharing all the required data with you on the next MBR as well, like as we normally do with the matrices and the get resolved rate, the utilization.
it's going to be a part of that particular MBR deck. NPS survey link, I will be sharing that in the chat over here so that it can be filled out. We are expecting a good score, 9 and 10, that's
what we aim for. In fact, we aim for 10. So that's what we will be aiming for this time as well.
The.
If you talk about, like, we will be going in for a QBR for next quarter as well. So we'll be going ahead and scheduling it with you, Glenn and Tim. So we'll be looking forward to see you on the next QBR as well.
Okay, very good.
Okay, so anything you want to add in Natalie before we wrap it up?
No, I think I'm pretty good.
Okay, let me quickly check if I can go ahead and share the NPS link. I wish also you have it handy. Will you be sharing it?
Yeah, no problem. I can just put a reference of that in NPS link in the team chat and I appreciate, Tim, if you can just spare some time to fill it in.
Pre it.
Yep, as soon as you put it in chat, I'll take care of it. Take it right away.
Uhh...
Thank you so much.
Sure. Thank you. Glenn, Tim, anything you want to add in before we wrap it up?
I don't have anything at this time.
K.
All right.
No, I think we're good. Let me just make sure I get this link before I just make sure I see it.
I got the link, so thank you. Appreciate it. Yep, I got it.
Yeah, it is. Perfect. Thank you. Thanks a lot, Tim. Thank you, Tim and Glenn, for your presence today. We'll be looking forward to meet with you again. And with Glenn, I meet him every month. And Tim, I will be looking forward to at least on the QBR the next one.
with you. So thank you for your time today. Have a great day ahead.
Yeah.
Thank you much.
Bye, everyone.
Thank you. Take care. Bye.
Thank you. Have a pleasant evening. Bye bye.
Have a great one.